[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour une
nouvelle saison du 7-8 dossier une
émission qui décrypte chaque mois une
thématique et pour la rentrée nous
ouvrons le dossier du logement étudiant
sur saint quentin en yvelines près de
17000 étudiants de l'université
versailles saint quentin sont accueillis
chaque année sur le territoire et
plusieurs solutions de logement s'offre
à eux
la location chez le particulier les
trois résidences du crous ou onze autres
résidences privées sur l'agglomération
avec des prix oscillant entre 300 et 800
euros en fonction de la surface mais
pour commencer je vous propose de
découvrir le logement intergénérationnel
c'est à dire une personne âgée qui
accueille chez elle un étudiant
regardez
[Musique]
elles cohabitent ensemble depuis 15
jours étudiante en licence
d'environnement ambre s'est installée
chez lucid pour cette année scolaire un
binôme formé par l'association
spécialisée dans le logement
intergénérationnel ensemble2générations
elles sont toutes les deux assez
indépendante mais je trouve qu'il ya
déjà une belle connivence qui s'installe
je sentais qu'elle pourrait très bien
s'entendre parce que très ouvert toutes
les deux très respectueuse du planning
de chacun et puis en se donnant des
rendez-vous temps en temps pour partager
des dîners lucile prépare un voyage à
berlin
l'étudiante n'hésite pas à lui donner
des conseils pour son séjour
ensemble2générations a déjà constitué
650 binôme dans les yvelines depuis la
création en 2006 trois formules sont
proposées pour les étudiants et les
seniors soient les étudiants sont logés
gratuitement en échange de présents ce
soir et la nuit
sinon on a une autre formule où
l'étudiant va rendre des services
et là le jeune va payer une petite
participation aux frais d'usagé
d'environ 80 100 euros par mois pour
couvrir les frais de gaz électricité et
puis une autre formule où le seigneur a
besoin d'un complément de revenus ou des
content aussi d'avoir une présence dans
la maison
ambre a choisi cette dernière option
elle paye un loyer inférieur à 300 euros
alors j'ai choisi ce genre de logement
parce que déjà d'un point de vue
économique c'est beaucoup mieux
et aussi et surtout parce que ça me
permet d'être en colocation avec
quelqu'un et de pas être tout seul
l'étudiante dispose de son étagère dans
la cuisine pour ses produits
alimentaires dans sa chambre elle a des
meubles pour ranger ses affaires
j'ai fait ma déco perso fatigue et j'ai
aussi une petite salle de bain et ça
c'est super parce que j'ai aussi mon
indépendance au niveau de la salle de
bain c'est juste quand je sors je là
prévient le week-end quand tu te bats
comme ce week-end où j'ai sur paris je
les préviens aussi pour lui dire que je
veux pas rentrer dans le week-end
seulement dix mille fois oui mais alors
bon week-end alors ouais
dimanche l'us il va passer le week-end
tout seul depuis 2010 elle accueille
chez elle des étudiants pour
l'association ensemble2générations je
pense que c'est difficile pour eux aussi
de se loger bien que moi je ne je
n'offre pas logement gratuit
ben pour moi c'est c'est une bouffée de
jeunesse ambre depuis le peu de temps
qu'elle est là elle m'a déjà aidé sur
internet parce qu'on a eu des problèmes
de connexion elle est beaucoup plus à
l'aise quand je suis en liga avec avec
la les dépanneurs ambre a aussi aidé
lucile pour remettre en place la
jardinière sur le balcon en 2017
ensemble2générations a déjà formé plus
de 75 binôme dans le département
entre l'école d'audiovisuel troisième
celle d'ingénieur l'estaca ou
l'université de versailles saint quentin
quinze mille étudiants se rendent chaque
jour à saint quentin en yvelines pour
faciliter leur installation sur le
territoire la communauté d'agglomération
a doublé son offre de logements en
l'espace de quelques années on avait à
peu près 1000 logements étudiants alors
qu'on est un pôle universitaire
important donc depuis ces trois
dernières années l'agglomération à
renforcer son offre et on a plus que
doublé l'offre de logements étudiants
puisqu'on est à plus de 2500 logements
étudiants jeunes aujourd'hui saint
quentin en yvelines compte 14 résidences
étudiantes
la dernière en date inaugurée l'an
dernier la résidence andré dunoyer de
segonzac à guyancourt 147 studio situé
juste à côté de lui vs qu avec des
loyers compris entre 395 et 455 euros et
un engagement porté sur l'environnement
c'est un peu un projet un peu innovant
effectivement aujourd'hui les questions
énergétiques sont un enjeu majeur
une attention particulière est apportée
à l' usage dans le logement pour que les
étudiants soient vigilants et permettre
de faire de cette résidence une
résidence passive dont qui produit
plutôt de l'énergie qu'elle en consomme
parmi les deux mille deux cent cinquante
logements du territoire saint quentin en
yvelines en attribue près de six ans
pour en bénéficier l'étudiant doit
remplir une fiche administratives auprès
de la direction de l'habitat
exactement comme un bailleur social
pourrait recevoir des demandes de
candidature là la direction habitat
traite des demandes de logement étudiant
et en fonction des demandes qu'elle
reçoit c'est une de ses missions ses de
positionner les candidats de positionner
de proposer des candidats aux
gestionnaires de résidences étudiantes
la direction de l'habitat se fait donc
le lien entre étudiants et gestionnaires
mais aussi avec les propriétaires lancé
depuis 2015 le site ce qui le cas vise
regroupe des annonces de particuliers
pour des locations chambres ou studios
en lien avec le crous et avec
l'université avec aussi des associations
partenaires au niveau en matière de
logement des jeunes sur le territoire
donc c'est une réflexion partagée et
ensuite c'est un site gratuit qui est
proposé aux propriétaires et aux
étudiants en recherche de logement
en différents dispositifs qui
permettront peut-être aux étudiants de
quitter le domicile familial
selon une étude unis placent publié en
2015 près de la moitié d'entre eux
vivent encore chez leurs parents
[Musique]
rejoignez un ça va
bienvenue chez les a' pierre-marie cette
étudiante en licence administration
économique et sociale est installé à la
résidence vauban du crous à guyancourt
un studio t1 meublés loués à plus de 400
euros le loyer très abordable
et donc voilà donc là c'est bien ce jour
ma salle de bain le démenti nous sont
proposés correspondent étudiant j'ai pas
besoin de grand-chose t'ai vu tu me lis
un bureau voilà ouverte en 1995 la
résidence vauban comporte 132 chambres
des studios t1 entre 402 et 409 euros
des t1 bis en colocation entre 329 et
332 euros en fin d'été 2 à 516 euros
il ya aussi une salle commune et une
laverie nos missions fondamentales c'est
d'appuyer l'étudiant dans la réussite de
ses études par le biais de tarifs
sociaux et aussi être des facilitateurs
du rôle social
de son brouillon de rôle social
accompagner les étudiants à organiser
des soirées mettre en place des lieux de
rencontres au sein de la résidence pour
créer une mixité sociale
c'est une volonté forte du directeur du
crous de versailles et de faire vivre
ces résidences pas seulement des lieux
de vie mais aussi des lieux de
socialisation
autre solution pour se loger se tourner
vers le parc privé avec notamment la
résidence daniel morellon espacil
filiale du groupe action logement est
spécialisé dans le logement social
elle est propriétaire et gestionnaire de
ces 154 logements des t1 entre 400 et
500 euros des t1 bis à 580 euros
dt 2 à 820 euros alors là nous sommes
dans un t1 bis donc de trois mètres
carrés le loyer de 587 euros
vous avez ici dans le t1 bis un espace
kitchenette donc avec frigo neuf sous
évier et plaques de cuisson donc assez
fonctionnel pour cuisiner ouverte le 1er
septembre 2016 cette résidence vise un
public particulier les doctorants et
s'est avéré qu'au bout de quelques mois
c'était un public qui était pas facile à
capter là on s'est orienté en début
d'année sur le un public complémentaires
que nous autorisait d'ailleurs les
diverses conventions
c'est à dire des étudiants à une laverie
une salle de travail et une salle
commune les gestionnaires ont un budget
pour organiser des soirées en 2017 cinq
résidences étudiantes ont été livrés à
saint quentin en yvelines
une bonne nouvelle j'ai appelé le crous
directement ils vont te faire
l'attribution du logement
ce sera il encore fin du calvaire pour
audrey lecouffe cette jeune étudiante en
master 2 originaire de lille va enfin
pouvoir poser ses valises et ses livres
dans la résidence rené cassin
d'elancourt
elle était en recherche active d'un
logement étudiant depuis fin août à
quelques jours de la reprise des cours
audrey a dû attendre deux semaines avant
d'avoir deux propositions pendant quinze
jours c'était c'était moi ma voiture et
mon sac quoi honnêtement c'était gens
réservent à la dernière minute un hôtel
haut à droite à gauche
je regarde à combien de kilomètres il
est de la fac je regarde où est ce que
je vais pouvoir me garer faire ceci cela
une recherche de dernière minute risqué
selon le responsable du service logement
il est conseillé de monter son dossier
avant les vacances estivales
et lorsque la recherche de logement
commence vers fin routes au mois de
septembre
la plupart des logements sont attribués
les offres il ya très peu d'offres est
généralement les offres qui restent sont
les plus élevés pour le crous du site
vers saint-quentin qui gère neuf
résidences universitaires et 1200 le
joue entre saint cloud il encourt la
procédure a été respectée
le risque zéro n'existe pas cependant on
a un taux de satisfaction que très élevé
et là en l'occurrence n'y a pas eu
dysfonctionnement il ya une demande
tardive
on était particulièrement réactif quelle
était la procédure
elles s'étaient d'abord adressés à nos
partenaires de l'université versailles
saint quentin qui nous ont transmis le
dossier pour plus de réactivité
la directrice des résidences
universitaires est allée elle-même
portel dossier aux services centraux
le 14 septembre dray en ménage enfin
dans son nouvel appartement à elancourt
un studio de 20 m² loués 377 euros sans
avoir déduit les aides personnalisées au
logement c'est les aléas en fait c'est
malheureusement si on n'est pas prêt à
vivre ça à notre âge on n'est pas prêt à
villepinte choses par la suite quoi ça
m'a plus perturbée au niveau du budget
ça c'est sûr heureusement mes parents
sont là d'ailleurs même si j'ai souvent
eu des jobs pour compenser quoi audrey
va maintenant se concentrer sur ses
études elle devrait rester dans son
logement étudiant à elancourt jusqu'au
mois de janvier et la fin de son diplôme
c'est la fin de ce premier numéro merci
de nous avoir suivis et si vous
souhaitez revoir cette émission en
replay vous pouvez la retrouver sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile tv 78 à bientôt pour l'ouverture
d'un nouveau dossier
[Musique]